female veterans face a unique number of
challenges including the risk for
homelessness 8 news now reporter Mary
Jane billiesza shares the programs in
place to house our female Veterans
for veterans in need coming to the
Salvation Army is more than just a place
to stay it means security and hope for
the future when they first come in you
know they they're not sure what to
expect but once they find out and get
the care from their case managers you
can see the attitudes and their emotions
and things change they open up more the
organization originally housed male
veterans and has now opened up a floor
to female veterans the Salvation Army of
Southern Nevada says there is a lack of
resources for female veterans they hope
to keep more people off the street by
expanding this housing program Monique
Irby the assistant coordinator for
veteran services at the Salvation Army
knows how critical this need is I come
from a family of veterans my husband is
a veteran my dad my grandfather her
uncles cousins a slew a family that were
veterans so this is very important to me
it's almost a passion in a sense funding
is on a case-by-case basis Juan Salinas
the director of Social Services for the
Salvation Army says they extended this
program a month ago the good thing that
we have also here they don't just stay
here we also make sure they're Fed so
they get three meals a day sometimes
four meals a day while they're staying
here with us currently there are five
female veterans in this program The
Salvation Army hopes to break that
stigma surrounding homelessness by
giving back to those who sacrifice so
much for our country I always tell my
staff the veterans or clients are the
experts because they have the experience
how can we teach them when they've been
the ones who's living in it